PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Cat-Out has decided
to set up their
packaging subscriber
as a serverless containerized
app on Cloud Run.
Keep watching to find out how.
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
In the last episode, we learned
about the different options
and authentication methods
that Cloud Pub/Sub supports
for push message delivery.
[JAZZY INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
We also setup Cloud Functions
as the push subscriber endpoint.
Today, let's set up Cat-Out's
packaging subscriber
application on serverless
platform Cloud Run.
But before we do that, Cloud
Run and Cloud Functions
are both serverless.
So when should you use
one over the other?
Well, Cloud Functions
are great for inventor
of an applications.
You deploy code as
functions like call them
via HTTP request, or set it to
trigger based on a background
event.
But it is possible
that for some services
you need more control over
the execution environment
and the language, or
you're already running
the service in a container.
In such cases, you
would want to set up
the service on Cloud Run, which
enables you to package code
in a stateless container, then
invoke it via HTTP requests.
So today, let's help Cat-Out
set up packaging service
as a push subscriber
endpoint on Cloud Run.
To get setup, log into
the Google Cloud console.
Select your project
and open Cloud Shell.
If you've not already played
with Python docs samples,
then clone the app
repository using git clone.
Then cd into the folder we
just downloaded, and go to run,
and then pubsub Then,
launch the editor
so we can see the code
for our application.
In the Explorer
on the left, find
the folder for Python samples
and go to run and pubsub.
Let's see what's going on here.
Main.py has the server set up
that handles incoming request.
Then, there's the handler that
processes the pubsub message
and logs a greeting,
hello world.
And it's also returning
a tool for response code.
Remember from the last
episode, the subscriber
needs to respond back with
success codes such as 200, 204,
et cetera, because it
acts as an acknowledgment
for the complete
processing of the message.
And if we return HTTP error
codes such as 400 or 500,
that indicates that the
message will be retried.
And, of course,
the Docker file--
that defines the operating
environment for the service.
The contents of the
Docker file will obviously
vary by the language
of your choice.
Now, in order to push
this code to Cloud Run,
we need to build a container,
push it to Container Registry,
and then deploy it.
So let's head on over
to our Cloud Shell,
and we will use gcloud
builds submit with tag
gcr.io/projectname/servicename.
We will see a success with the
source and the image address.
Now we're ready to deploy, and
for that we execute the command
gcloud run deploy, the
name of the service,
which in this case
is packaging-service,
and provide the image
address, which is
gcr.io/projectid/container-name.
For this example, I'm choosing
Cloud Run fully managed option,
but you can select Anthos, too.
Select the region.
I picked US central, here.
We have to say no to the
allow authenticator prompt
because we only want Pub/Sub to
access the packaging service.
Once it is deployed, we
have the service URL.
When we click on it, it
leads us to forbidden.
This is expected
since we said no
to the unauthenticated front.
At this point, we have
the packaging service.
Now, how do we integrate
this service with Pub/Sub
so our order topic
can send messages
to the packaging subscriber?
Well, let's see.
We go to IAM and enable Pub/Sub
to create authentication tokens
in our project.
We locate the Cloud Pub/Sub
service account and add a role,
service account
token creator, to it.
Then we create the
service account
to represent the Pub/Sub
subscription identity.
For that, we go to
service accounts in IAM
and create a new
service account.
Now, we will give
the invoker service
the account permissions it
needs to invoke our packaging
service.
For this, we use
gcloud run service,
add IAM policy binding, the name
of our service, which we called
packaging-service, the member,
which is our service account,
and the role is invoker.
Now we create the
Pub/Sub subscription
for our packaging service
with this service account.
We execute the command gcloud
pubsub subscriptions create,
provide the name of the
subscription, topic that we
want to be associated with.
In our case, it's order_topic.
The push endpoint needs to
be our Cloud Run service URL,
and the push auth
service account flag
activates the Pub/Sub
push functionality
for authentication
and authorization.
We go to Pub/Sub and see that
our subscription is created.
With that, Cat-Out's
packaging service
is fully integrated
with Pub/Sub,
and we are ready to send a
message from order publisher
to our packaging subscriber.
And to verify that our Cloud Run
packaging subscriber received
it, we go to the
logs in Stackdriver
and filter on Cloud Run.
And we see that the
message is received.
So there you have it.
We just set up an integration
between Cloud Pub/Sub and Cloud
Run.
All right, so today
we helped Cat-Out
deploy a push
subscriber on Cloud Run
and receive messages
from the older
service using Cloud Pub/Sub.
Stay tuned for the
next episode, where
we will help Cat-Out
replay and purge messages.
Until then, give us
a like, subscribe,
and let us know what you want
to learn about Cloud Pub/Sub.
[INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]